United Airlines and Alaska Airlines say
that they found loose Hardware on door
plugs on several of their grounded
Boeing 737 Max 9 planes days after a
door plug blew off of an an Alaska
Airlines plane while it was in Flight
apparently by just pure dumb luck there
didn't happen to be anybody sitting in
the seat right next to where the hole
blew open uh if if there had been
someone there you know they wouldn't be
here anymore they would probably be in
several different places strewn across
the state of Oregon and now they tell
tell us that there are loose bolts on a
bunch of uh different planes a bunch of
different 737 Max 99's all have these
loose bolts which is I mean the kind of
thing you don't like to hear about
planes to put it mildly you know if
somebody's talking about loose bolts or
loose screws or something like that
should be referring to Ikea furniture
not passenger Jets